maintenant il faut se dire toujours par
expérience un médicament on va dire qui
a fait l'objet d'un très bonne essais
thérapeutiques comme c'est probablement
le cas donnent souvent des résultats un
peu moins bons en population en vie
réelle pourquoi parce que dans un essai
thérapeutique on sélectionne évidemment
les patients qui corresponde finalement
pas au patient réel de la vie voilà il
va arriver quand en france alors bas
dans les prochains jours nyon vanille
voilà donc
l'agencé européenne du médicament a
donné son autorisation maintenant il
faut que les agences françaises donnent
leur accord que le prix soit fixé pour
qu'il puisse être commercialisé serré
que la france achète le médicament
auprès du laboratoire d'ailleurs
celui-ci va le faire fabriquer en france
je crois qu'il a investi 250 millions
d'euros sur cinq ans pour le faire
fabriquer en france est ce que à terme
on parce que commence équivalent il ya
plusieurs doses de vaccins dont
plusieurs médecins disent qu'il va
falloir se faire vacciner tous les ans
skt en ce médicament peut remplacer le
vaccin est qu'on puisse se dire voilà
pour les vacciner que les personnes à
risque alors on va dire le vaccin permet
d'acquérir une immunité pour éviter de
faire une forme grave le médicament est
un traitement une fois qu'on a été
infectée éventuellement pour ne pas se
retrouver en réanimation mais je dirais
dans un premier temps la vaccination
était très importante pour monter
l'immunité collective pour permettre
justement aux virus de vivre on va dire
harmonieusement avec l'homme pour éviter
qu'ils lui donnent une maladie grave
donc on voit que l'évolution vers pau
mikron va dans le bon sens et on espère
évidemment que les variants avenir 1
seront des virus de type rhume qui vont
très bien coexister avec l'homme qui ne
donneront pas sauf cas exceptionnel
c'est des personnes très fragile une
maladie grave donc la vaccination était
très importante pour permettre
l'acquisition de cette immunité
collective alors par la suite on ne sait
pas encore à quel rythme il faudra faire
des rappels pour booth et l'immunité
pour lui permettent évidemment bas de
s'équilibrer avec les variants car on
sait que le virus ne disparaîtra pas de
la planète il y à des réservoirs humain
il ya surtout des réservoirs animaux et
donc beaucoup varian peuvent émerger
encore donc il faut être encore prudent
mathieu docteur du coup aujourd'hui si
plus du tout la peine et saidal et qu'on
marque les six millions de personnes non
vaccinées de le faire puisqu'on sait
maintenant le seul risque c'était la
forme grave et quand même maintenant
grâce à ce médicament au cas où il y
aurait une forme grave on prend le
médicament dans les trois jours on l'a
plus c'est qu'on peut laisser les 6
milliards alors je je dirais non en fait
il faut vraiment convaincre tout le
monde de se faire vacciner parce que
d'abord comme on sait il vaut mieux
prévenir que guérir oui c'est quand même
délicat de dire que ma vie est suspendue
un médicament que je vais prendre avec
un risque toujours de faire une forme
grave de la maladie ensuite on ne sait
pas aujourd'hui quelles vont être les
variants à venir et lorsque ce
médicament va être utilisée il est fort
à parier que des résistances vont
apparaître parmi les virus qui vont
circuler et ce médicament pourrait
perdre de son efficacité mais on va dire
il ya un espoir parce que c'est le début
des médicaments anti qu'ovide d'autres
médicaments vont évidemment apparaître
par la suite